And so, and welcome to today's episode of
Rawkode Live at Rawkode Academy.
Today, we are doing a hands on session
looking at how Rust and asynchronous programming work
together.
Before we do that, there's a little bit
of housekeeping.
Please like, comment, share, and subscribe all the
things on YouTube.
Can always find this channel available at Rawkode.live.
Also, we have membership options available and courses
where you can come and learn the complete
guide to InfluxDB.
We'll check out the different options available there,
and feel free to jump into the Discord.
We have around 500 people in there now
talking all things cloud native, Kubernetes, and everything
in between.
So come and say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
Okay. So
because
I am not a Rust person well, I'm
trying to be, but my synchronous Rust is
pretty poor as Samuel is gonna find out.
You have a wonderful guy today. So, hey,
Samuel. How are you doing? Good. Thanks. And
yourself? Yeah. Yeah. I'm doing alright today.
Awesome. It's always fun to be able to
write a little bit of Rust for people,
so it's gonna be awesome. Yeah. I'm I'm
sure it's gonna be great. I'm excited. Awesome.
Can you
tell us a little bit about you and
introduce it off to the audience, please? Yeah.
Sure. So, yeah, I'm Samuel, as as Dave's
mentioned.
Cool. So, yeah, I work as a
platform engineer at a company called Aerobotics.
It's a company in Cape Town, South Africa
where I live.
And,
yeah, we build software for the agriculture industry
using
a whole lot of nice buzzwords of drones,
AI, machine learning, blah blah blah. Really cool
stuff.
I actually started off as a data scientist,
surprisingly,
and then about, like, a year and a
bit in,
figured I enjoyed engineering more,
and so moved over.
And then,
yeah, I've been, like, doing Rust,
like, in my free time for, like, a
year, roughly. So,
yeah, it's pretty much how I ended up
here.
I'm
assuming being originally a data scientist, you must
you must be a Python developer as well.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. I know. I know a
lot of Python.
So what caught your attention about about Rust?
So at the time so this was last
year. So, yeah, last year, was basically learning
a bunch of programming languages. So last year
was, like, my first year as a full
time developer,
and
I was just learning languages because everyone's like,
learning new languages makes you a better programmer.
So I started off with Haskell. That went
terribly.
Wow. Jump in on the deep end. Yeah.
I know. It wasn't it wasn't a great
it wasn't a great time. Honestly,
couldn't really figure out left from right there.
And so then moved on to
I tried closure. That was that was a
great experience.
Did a little bit of go, and then
then at some point, I was like, let
me learn Rust. And that yeah. I read
the book.
I know yeah. I mean, just from there,
it just caught my attention as, like, a
really interesting language, and then also solved a
lot of problems that, like, I had seen
developers make in in Python, myself included. So
for instance,
like, a function just returning none or some
random value or whatever, and then it blows
up in your face at runtime or whatever.
So there was situations like that, and I
was like, you know, Rust has these nice
guarantees,
and, like, kinda, like, you know, forces you
to program it in a in a bit
of a better way in my opinion. So
that that kind of, like, just stuck with
me. And then
I've stumbled upon awesome Rust mentors,
And then from there,
found a bunch of people in the Rust
community, and they just stuck. Like, that was
that
was it for me. So, yeah, since then,
pretty much been
doing Rust like in my personal time as
much as possible.
Yeah. I think the the Rust community is
it should be like an example of how
to make a welcoming programming community. Just always
taken aback by how happy and charitable everyone
is with their time and their knowledge. Like,
just it doesn't matter what your problem is
or what you run up against. There just
seems to be always someone they're willing to
help.
Hundred percent. Yeah. It's it's really amazing. And
I think it's it's probably one of the
biggest contributors to our Rust is doing so
well as a language.
Just because it's a difficult language to learn
and so having a a community that's there
to support you through it actually makes a
lot of difference. Yeah.
Yeah. I've I've been writing Rust for a
little while now and still bang my head
against the table quite often. So Yeah. No.
It is definitely difficult to learn. But I
am writing much more functionally correct code because
of, the type system and the guarantees and
the and all that. So
Awesome. Sure.
Alright. Can you then do us a favor
and maybe just tell us a little bit
about what we mean by asynchronous
programming?
Sure. So
yeah. So just
for context, like, I am I started learning
about, like, async, I think, late last year.
Well, I mean, I started learning about Rust
late last year, but it's been a it's
been an interesting journey. And so
the the I guess, most exciting thing about
async for me was that I could actually
learn, like, the details of it,
and so kind of, like, how I got
here. So with async programming, like, the main
idea is to solve, let's say, a class
of problems that allow your
code or applications to be more scalable.
And so you basically wanna run like concurrent
software. So you wanna handle multiple tasks all
at one time. Mhmm.
And this is good for things like web
service. So I I guess that's like the
canonical use case
where,
you know, you have like multiple in flight
requests and you wanna be able to handle
them all. Obviously, if somewhat taking
extremely long or your concurrency model isn't that
great,
you're gonna have,
like, request backlog and then just start getting
500.
Yeah, async async programming programming kinda, like, came
in to fit that void as far as
I understand. And so
the the main
use case or way it fits in the
basis with IO bound tasks. So that's with
most of the time taken for their, like,
execution is or what's dominated by waiting. So
if you can think about it like
making a a database call, for instance,
you do a bunch of work, make a
database call,
wait until it it resolves, until you get
in your information back, and then you can
continue working. So there's, a big span of
time
that's spent waiting.
And so, effectively, what you wanna do is
kind of, like, maximize the amount of time
that the CPU is being utilized. So you
don't wanna keep wait you don't wanna have
this dead time where
a request comes in and then you've gotta
wait, and then nothing happens between when you
make that request to the database and when
you get the information back.
And so async programming kind of fits in
that way by allowing tasks to
basically, like,
give up the or, like, yield the execution
to the CPU at points in time and
say, like, I've made a request.
I'm gonna be busy waiting. So something else
can run-in the meantime. And then when that
thing finishes right or, like, when I'm ready
to run again, I'll let you know, and
then I'll proceed to run. And so that
it's just kind of, like, unlocked a lot
of
performance.
And so
yeah. I mean, yeah, that's pretty much pretty
much it. Long long explanation.
No. That that works really well. You know,
like, I think when I when I
first started working, like, in code professionally,
and I won't give you a year because
that'll show my age, but, you know, I
was working with with parallel and PHP languages,
which doesn't actually have, like, any native concurrency
or asynchronous primitives And then Mhmm. Blocking the
the request. Well, like, you know, request comes
in and then blocking, so you make some
other external questions in the back. Yeah. It's
just not gonna ever scale. Right? Like, concurrency
and asynchronous.
I understand. Yeah. I've had, like, a quite
a bit of
experience with Tango's kind of, like, sync
model. So it's kind of like a
basically, you can think about, a thread per
request.
And so what happens if, like, if any
part of your of your request is really
slow, then all of a sudden, get this,
like, huge backlog of requests coming Exactly. Coming
back because something might take, like I don't
know. Let's say, like, in a bad, bad
example for instance, like, if something took two
seconds and your requests are coming in at,
like,
every millisecond or something, yeah, because, obviously, things
are gonna go wrong. Right? So
so, yeah, async really fits that
that specific, like, problem
space and, yeah, basically solves for that.
Yeah. I think, you know, maybe a a
lot of the people that subscribe to the
channel may be familiar with Go, which has
a relatively hands off asynchronous model and that
you never really need to worry about it.
You just say, go run this thing in
the background. Yeah. Rust doesn't quite like that.
Right? It's a bit more
complicated.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think I actually I actually think
that goes way of doing it. Like, okay.
I don't have very
informed opinions here, but I do think that
it's actually quite a nice
way of handling it in the sense that
because it effectively does
the same thing, but just behind the scenes.
So you as a as a dev don't
have to worry about actually writing, like, async
await. I
don't know actually which one's better or, like,
the economics of either. But, yeah, in Rust
I think in Rust, I think Nodes,
JS,
Python,
and a few others, yeah, it's really explicit.
So you'd have to write, like, you know,
your
your code with async await and have your
red or colored functions as as that essay
says.
The Rust model seems to be really similar
to the node one. At least I see
a lot of similarities and even just the
syntax and some of the like, for me
the problem parts is always like you have
to defend your function that says sync and
then it has to be called from an
asynchronous context. You can't just go through it
around
a waste anywhere, which in the Go world
is unheard of because in Go you'd literally
just put Go before a phone call and
that's it. Right? It just it just does
it. But with with Node and with Rust,
the similarities are there and I have to
actually think up front about where I need
the concurrency to happen or Yes. Whatever. And
then I think my first time trying to
write is synchronous Rust and realizing that I
had to have the executor
context on the main function that then delegated
the access and blah blah blah. I was
just like, ah, it's like
Yeah. Definitely. It is it is definitely difficult.
Maybe a little bit overwhelming.
I guess for me, like, that's that was
my introduction to async programming in the first
place, so I kind of missed it.
You're you're gonna make it easier for all
of us today. Right?
Hopefully.
But yeah.
Yeah. I I really enjoy, like,
so far as as much as I've as
played around with asynchronous stuff. I've enjoyed it
so far, but I have heard there are
some pain points, I think, for a lot
of people that are using it in production.
So but it's also still new. So we'll
get there.
Alright. Well, how do you wanna kick this
off? Do wanna will we move over to
the screen share and start writing some code?
Yeah. Let's do that. Let's definitely
I think that'll I think that'll be fun.
Alright. We can see Versus code, but you
may have to pump the font size up
a little bit. Okay. Cool. Cool. Yeah. Let
me do that.
I think you can just command plus a
few times
or change it earlier. That would work too.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Go 20 go 24.
That's what I use.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah. Now we're kicking. Like it. Awesome. Awesome.
I bet that's massive on your side, though.
Right? Yeah. I know. Really
is vegan and Spanish because I use, like,
or something ridiculous like that as my normal
font. So 24 is is huge. But it's
actually it's actually a great quality of life.
We've got a hello from Javier in the
chat. Hey. What's up, Javier? Yeah. I know.
Cool.
So,
yeah, I was thinking, like, it would be
cool to kind of, like, run through just
a bit of the
kind of, like, basics
of
async and just kind of, like,
walk through some very beginner stuff and kind
of, like, break some sort of, like, assumptions
that we might have of it or whatever.
So Perfect.
Cool. So,
firstly,
yeah, one thing I think that's become, like,
a big deal in async is, like, the
executor. So, you know, we've got like Tokyo
and async standard, and then they're not entirely
compatible and whatever.
So you basically have to choose your one
upfront and, like, ecosystems are built around each
one. For for this use case, I'm gonna
use Tokyo purely because
I know
some stuff about Tokyo and don't know too
much about ASX standards. So it's nothing nothing
against the ASX standard piece.
But, yeah, I mean, it's just basically all
I know. So
yeah. Basically, just like a quick
just running through, like, a quick
creating a quick
asynchronous function.
So Tokyo is the executor,
and then it's it's got, like, an entry
point. So in this case, this async fun
main.
And
yeah. I mean, this is basically all we
need to do to make code
asynchronous so we can actually enable, so increase
the font of my
let's
see.
I think the size of the sidebar is
okay if that's what you're worried about. Oh,
the terminal. The terminal.
Let's see. Oh, there we go. Yeah. Perfect.
Sweet.
Cool. Yeah. So this is basically all you
need to do to make a
asynchronous
or make your code asynchronous in the beginning.
For the purpose of this one, I'm I
prefer to use so
you can use a
multi threaded or single threaded async
executor.
What's going on now?
What did I do?
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I think that might work. Ah, yeah. There
you go. Currently. So,
yeah, you can have a multi threaded or
single threaded one. For the purposes of this
bunch of recommendation, she's a current
rate, which is just a single thread executor.
I think it's a bit easier to understand
the model. So I actually have this image
here that I was so I was actually
writing a blog post at some point that
I never got to finishing.
But you can imagine that, like, let's say
we have task a and b here,
and it's executing. So this part portion is
where it's doing some work. This part where
it's empty is it's waiting.
Similar for task b here.
All of all both of these tasks will
run on, the same thread. So task a
will run.
They will just start it with task a.
Then when it gets to this yield point,
it'll give up control. So
in async, tasks are cooperatively scheduled, which just
means that they themselves told the execute like,
the executor when they're
when they're,
like, blocked, and then they'll give up the
the CPU, basically.
And so it works on, like so you
have to have, like, basically, like, good access.
So in in this case, what'll happen is
if you had, a CPU bound task and
it never yielded the CPU, then nothing else
would be be able to run at the
wall just be blocked in essence.
But, yeah, we have this, like,
task a, which runs, and then we have
then it yields
the CPU, and then task b will start
running, but it's all on the same thread.
This is a bit easier to understand than
having it on multiple threads.
It does the same thing, but, like, on
multiple threads, basically.
Cool. So, yeah, this is basically
all we need to have an async
function. And if we can't go around this,
Actually, it will compile and work.
Yeah. I've heard the Rust compiler is really
fast.
Said nobody ever. It's it's working literally. Also,
on a MacBook, it's arguably also
not as fast as of others. Cool. So,
yeah, we've we've run this function. We've got
a hello world out.
Feels very synchronous, so nothing too crazy.
And effectively,
it's well, it's not, but effectively, it's run
a synchronous in a synchronous fashion.
And just to
just to kind of, like, unpack this, so
this
Tokyo main
flavor current thread is effectively the same as
this. So it's obviously a macro, and
it does the same
thing as
let's see. I can comment this out.
So these two things are equivalent,
barring that there's no comment. And
so, basically, what happens is it creates a
new runtime, and then it has this block
on method.
And what this does
is,
as it says here, it's
it'll run the feature and then block until
it's complete.
And so, basically, this this here is here
is your feature, and you have this read
feature. So features are often made up of
other features. And so in the case of,
like, let's say, a web server or whatever,
you'll have, like, this outmost feature and then
all of your tasks running.
Okay. Yeah. It's running.
All of your tasks running within that feature.
And then only when this root feature, so
the, like, top level feature results will this
finish.
And so, yeah, basically, we have this async
function here, which does the same thing. So
this should effectively give us the same
outputs.
Let's see. Yeah. Hello. So we've we've we've
come full circle
and pretty much got the same thing.
But yeah. Now we can try and do
some more sort of, like, useful stuff. For
instance, so let's say
we wanted to
so
let's say you wanted to just make, a
request using
request
so we can use a
the request is async, basically, it uses Tokyo
underneath. And so let's say we so we
can create a client.
The request is a h HTTP client?
Yeah. Yeah. It's a HTTP client.
So you can get a new client.
Think this is will work. Let's say,
get.
What is this? You're all gonna think. Rustling.
Okay. Cool.
So this dot send is a
this return this actually returns a feature, this
dot send.
And and then we've gotta await that feature
to basically run it. So one thing about
Rust's
async
model
is that features don't run until they're pulled,
which is basically just to say that
they do nothing. They're, like, late they're lazy
by nature. So they do nothing until
you kinda, like, force them to run or
or drive them to run, which is what
this await does. So if you don't use
start awaits, nothing will happen. So if you
create a future and never create you the
result, then that future will never run?
So, yeah, if you if you never await
a future, it'll it'll basically never run. Okay.
So we can we can actually, like,
test that out. So firstly, let let's maybe
just, like, print
a
let's just do something simple.
So
in this case, the same thing.
So we'd expect this to return, like, a
200.
It'll just be, like, response time.
I should definitely get a fast computer.
It's not good. It's the compiler.
Cool. So we got this two hundred hours.
But let's say we
didn't run this. So
instead, we
just had send here
and then did nothing with that
with this. So now you can actually see
from the
from Rust Analyzer that this output is a
future with some response in error.
And, okay, now we're getting an error here.
So this nothing will happen here, basically, but
there's nothing that's gonna get
you can't actually print a future. So Can
we can I make a suggestion?
Could
we, like,
create a a function that just touches an
empty file on the disk and then schedule
that and then
not await it and the file wouldn't be
created? But if we did await it, the
file would be created? We probably we can
do that. We can do that. Then we
figure out how to do that. I guess
even just a even a print line statement
would work. Like, if we wouldn't see the
print hello if the, you know, if the
future of the asynchronous function was to print
hello, we shouldn't see any output, I guess.
It would be the same effect. Sorry.
What what do you think? I missed that.
Yeah. We you I was just saying your
actual your idea is better. Like, if we
just do a print inside of the future
like, if we create a new function called
async, print hello. Like, it should never print
hello if we don't know where to Yeah.
Yeah. Rather than trying to remember how to
do the fail system calls because I definitely
don't remember. Yeah.
So let's say, yeah, print hello.
So
takes nothing, and then let's just close
the Rawkode.
Cool.
So
in this case,
we could actually just say
oh, so let's say, like, we'll get
feature equal
So in this case, like, we would expect
so pretty much this Hello Rawkode wouldn't run
about this print line
would. Yeah.
Yeah. So if we do that, then
that's pretty much what should happen. Okay. So
now it's telling us that we didn't use
That is just a warning. That can't So
you can see, like, you know, this hello
gets printed, but then if you go, like,
future dot await,
then you should see hello Rawkode and then
and then the hello. Right? Yeah. So that's
pretty much what we've gotten by awaiting this
feature.
An interesting thing, though, is that this
technically is still just running synchronously.
So even though we've got this, like, async
and Tokyo is running,
there's not multiple tasks being run at the
same time. So
we can
can do that just using let's say, we
can make some multiple requests.
And there are some interesting things here.
My account, so if we have
And
then
if that same request again, so
try and go.
Just give me a second.
Yeah, there's quite a few interesting things that
could happen here.
So if you've got this and we kind
of, like, duplicate
this again,
so if we have So you're gonna make
two HTTP requests? Two requests. Yeah.
So if we do that, then okay. Let's
call this, like, results or response one,
and then this response two.
What will happen is that still
in this setup
Okay. It's the right number one.
This will still be
synchronous?
Yeah. It'll still it'll still basically be synchronous.
We'll have
and then.
It's live taping.
Yeah.
Cool. So in this case, it's basically actually
still synchronous here because
parts aren't really being spawned
to run asynchronously.
So in this case,
it'll still it'll still run. So even though
this this result one will
be like an IO task, so
it has to wait for a response. It'll
just still run-in
the order that it's that it's there. And
so
we can actually get around this.
Alright. So still still in order. And if
you run it multiple times, it'll continue to
be in order.
And so
get it to actually start using
async
properly, I guess, then we can start spawning
tasks. So Tokyo has this thing called spawn,
which I think
it's Tokyo.
Yeah.
And this spawn takes, an async function, basically.
I
copy this right now.
Cool.
Alright.
Yeah. And so this will spawn another task
onto the the executor,
these will run-in
asynchronously,
basically. But we might also find some weird
behavior coming out of here, which could be
quite interesting. So
let's say
So we have that.
Then what we want
here.
Time.
Cool. So so
what did I do now?
Alright.
It doesn't matter. Cool. So now we have
these two tasks basically being spun up. So
this spawn will spawn an asynchronous task onto
onto Tokyo, and this will do. So these
weren't these weren't blocked. So what we'd expect
here is for
so because these get scheduled asynchronously,
you would expect this to run this print
line run async first and then
whichever
order is complete.
It might still complete in the same order
it's been written
purely because,
yeah, the one request happened earlier than the
other. But sometimes it doesn't. I had fun
yesterday figuring that out.
So
if you run that,
then
cool. So
yeah. So this is actually an interesting an
interesting outcome here. And so this has to
actually do with the fact that, like,
there's
when I was talking about
having root features and features
or a root task and then task being
spawned within sort of, like, this root task
or being a combination of other features,
what's technically happened here is that that block
on function that I had earlier
or that I showed earlier,
it only waits for the top level feature
to resolve. And so what's happened is that
these two tasks have spun off, but then
the top level feature is basically like
this
in essence.
Yeah. And so when when it got here,
then it's finished. The top level feature is
finished,
and so
it just doesn't
complete the rest. So a quick way of
actually handling this is to is to use
Tokyo joint.
And
this basically just says it waits for each
task to finish before completing, basically. So it'll
wait for a lead. And spawn returns, like,
these things called join handle.
Yeah. I think I've had this problem before
when I've been doing asynchronous.
I'm like, why is it not running?
Yeah.
It's a bit of it's a bit of
interesting one. So, yeah, in this case, now
we've got this, like,
Tokyo joint, and then this will basically wait
for these two to finish. So I don't
know which order they'll finish in. It say
it can change. It could be in the
same order. But now we'd expect to see
run async and then the status
of these two things being printed.
Cool.
There you go. Oh, two first. Oh, two
first. Cool.
So
so yeah. So now you can see that
now this is actually all running asynchronously,
yeah. I mean, which is the call and
and exactly what we wanted
out of that system,
basically.
Okay. Can I just
summarize this so that I make sure I
understand this all correctly?
A %.
Okay. So
can you scroll up one line?
There we go. Okay. So we have this
Rust
macro,
which is the Tokyo main, and where you're
setting it to use an executor which is
current or a single threaded.
That macro
is
doing the boilerplate that you pasted earlier which
sets up a Tokyo executor
blocks on an asynchronous function which is an
essence just our main function.
Yes. Now here you have two different requests
using two different clients to the Rustlang website,
which are being blocked on using the await
syntax.
Those are both spawned asynchronously
using Tokyo spawn construct, which just a asynchronous
function and runs it in the background and
returns you a handle to that asynchronous task.
Mhmm. And then at the bottom, you are
using a Tokyo macro again, allows us to
just wait on all of those pending tasks
that we have by passing in the handle
and letting it do its thing. Yeah. Pretty
much. Okay.
I got one question then. Hello? Is the
standard procedure to then
let me see if this is right.
Do we need the two clients, or could
we create the client on a higher level
than a function and pass it into the
asynchronous functions?
Or is it would you just try and
isolate that as much as possible and have
multiple clients?
So
it's it's a bit of a difficult one,
mainly because
so
it's not, like, extremely
concrete in my mind yet.
But
in so in this case, when you spawn
something like the
the the task normally takes ownership of those
of those variables in that case. So in
this case, client, we wanted to be owned
by a certain task and and all these
tasks. And I and I'm not entirely sure
why,
though, I mean, like, just a a broad
assumption there's
you want a task to own, like, its
entire
or, like, all of the variables it uses
because task can also get, like, shipped across
threads, for instance.
So you it might let's say, in a
multithreaded context, it might start off on thread
one, but then end up on, like, thread
three, for instance. Mhmm.
And so
yeah. I'm I'm, like, pretty sure that's probably
a big reason why
it needs to needs to own
its variables.
And so I'm not sure about
kind of, like, passing in the same client
into multiple tasks. I'm pretty sure it could
probably be possible, but I I don't have
enough knowledge there.
I'll I'll I'll take that. Also, I'm curious
about the join handle. Is is that a
feature itself? Can we await the join handle
if we want to do it? I actually
don't think so. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. I don't I don't think
it's I don't it's actually
no. It doesn't look like it. Okay. Doesn't
look like it's Alright. We have a a
question in the chat as well from Russell
who's asking, is the lazy execution mechanism the
same depending on the executor behavior?
For example, if you choose multi threads rather
than a single thread, does an async function
only get called when awaited as well?
Yeah. So that that kind of, like, model
with the
with
futures or tasks only being run when they're
awaited, that's just like a Rust construct. How
that's handled
sort of like
by your executors
is just like an implementation detail. So,
yeah, it's basically it's basically just like how
the languages are solved for that. And I
think the
the reason why
it's built like that is because
for for them to be zero cost.
And so
what's happened,
at least from what I've read, is early
on, Rust actually had its own,
like,
sort of, like, green threading library.
And so
but that had, like, global costs. So,
basically, it would put put a performance cost
on in using Rust whether you use those
that set of functionality or not.
And so
with having lazy features, it it basically means
that, like, no work actually happens before, and
they're and they're compiled down to state machine.
And so no work happens before, so you
can use them and there's or you can,
like, create them and use them freely. And
and if you don't await them or have
an executor, then you pay no performance benefits.
Obviously, then they're useless, but
that's the that's that's the premise. So I
think I think it's gotta do more with
the
with the kind of, like, design constraints that
Rust Lang imposes by having that zero cost
guarantee.
And so that's why
it's
it's set up in this way. But nothing,
like, happens automatically. Whereas, like, Python or whatever,
once you start the event loop,
it just does its thing. You know? And
same with, like, node and others.
Alright. Perfect.
Cool.
Sweet. And so yeah. So that's pretty much
on some Tokyo stuff. I was also thinking
it would be cool to kind of, like,
run through
a bunch of stuff around futures themselves just
because I pretty much find that interesting and
just talking around, like, how they're created, what
they do,
all of that jazz. Yeah.
Let's do that.
So
k.
Sweet.
So
just give me a sec. Sorry.
Cool. Yeah. So, obviously, we've been talking a
lot about features and tasks and whatever. And
so,
yeah, basically, like a feature
represents
or it's kind of like canonical definition is
it represents some work
that'll be competed in the future. So it's
like some computation that'll be competed in future.
Rust is a little bit different purely because
that feature, like, it has to be pulled
kind of like manually.
And so you can see that,
let's say
and so yeah. Then we have these like
async
keywords. And so basically, async is just a
way
to denote
a function basic, but it basically just returns
the future. So if I do like this,
like,
this future
is
some async and just some number, you can
see that this return is something that implements
future,
and its output is
is an integer.
If you make it something else like unit
type, you get this, like, unit type outputs.
Let me just use this one. Yeah.
And if you do, a string,
you'll get an string. So bay and so
yeah. A feature in Rust is basically something
that's oh, what am I saying? That is
is
basically something that implements the future traits.
And so yeah. In this case,
in this case, like, we've got this feature
that
basically just returns 16
here. Yep.
Can people that are familiar with the node
ecosystem just replace future with promise in their
head and it's like the same thing?
I think so.
It kinda looks that way, so I think
I'll I'll just try and do that. I
think so. I'm not entirely sure. I don't
I don't have too much operating experience with
JS or Node JS. Lucky you.
Yeah.
I avoided that one.
Cool. Yeah. So, I mean, we have this
feature again,
like, you know, we can go and do
some work here, and this
obviously won't do anything
until we await it.
Oh, sorry.
Cool.
So
yeah, and so we have this feature. And
so, like, a
big question I had, like, initially when I
started is, like, what exactly is going on
with the future and, like, how does it
run?
So we can actually
do some cool stuff here. So let's I
just need to
just import a bunch of stuff. So
let me actually just copy and paste this
because this just be way easier.
Cool.
So
let's say you wanted to make so we
can make our own feature. It's actually not
that difficult to make a very boring feature,
so we're gonna just do that. So let's
say we have this
ending future.
Are you gonna tell me that futures are
just a tree implementation?
Technically,
yeah.
Everything in Rust is always a tree implementation.
Trades are trades are beautiful. They're really they're
really great.
So there's no there's no wonder.
Cool. So we can create a oh, what
did I do? Yeah.
Yeah. We can create a trade by implementing
future for what this thing that we've called
pending future.
Cool.
And this is basically the
the
structure of that
of of the future traits. And so we
have to have this top output. This is
like an associated top, so we're just gonna
return basically nothing.
So it's just an implementation
of a pull function that checks to see
if the work is completed and then returns
it?
Yeah. Pretty much. Pretty much. Nice. And so
okay. Cool. So what'll happen is that when
when you pull, it'll return this kind of
like pull object here. And this can either
be pull pending or pull ready. Those are
the two, like, variants. So pending already.
And so
we're gonna do something, like, really interesting here
where we're just gonna return pull pending
and, like, prints.
I've been pulled.
Mhmm.
So
yeah. And so what'll happen is, like, basically,
when the
executor
runs in your way, the task, it'll basically
start pulling your task for you.
And then there's, like, a whole lot of
details there.
So we can make a pending future here.
That's
the other ring. And
the wait. But
the interesting thing here is that,
basically, we'll see when it runs,
whenever that is. Cool. So we've got this,
like, I've been pulled, and then now our
executors actually hang. So, like, there's nothing nothing's
happening.
And the reason why is because,
as I said earlier, like, we've got this,
like, outermost feature,
and that feature
what's the name of it for? Like
oh, it's blocked on that outermost feature. And
so this, like, feed and so this one
that we've created
internally,
it has it it never completes. So by
having this poll pending, it's basically never completes.
And so
the outermost feature won't also complete, and therefore,
it just hangs, and so nothing happens. So
we can also
And kinda curious,
like Yeah. It only pulled once. Like, I
would expect it to maybe to pull more
than once. Is that something that's then controlled
by the implementation?
Yeah. So that that's actually an interesting thing
and also like a great
or just like a
thing that Rust did. So we can actually
we can actually we can actually fix that.
So let's say,
I saw this trick the other day. It's
actually cool.
So
then I can explain it later. Okay. Cool.
So if you do this
if
I think this should work.
So
in this case,
we should see a lot of output here,
hopefully.
Yeah. You can see There we go. So
quick. Yeah. Right?
Stop. Kiggle.
That's kind of what I I actually expected
that behavior by default. So maybe you can
Yeah. Walk me through that one. Yeah. Cool.
So
that's basically like the the way
kind of like Rust has set up the
system. So the idea is that when
a task gets pulled and it doesn't complete,
you don't wanna, like, keep pulling it all
the time. So you don't wanna have you
don't want it to be like this busy
dude where it's like, hey. Have you finished?
Hey. Have you finished? Hey. Have you finished?
And then it keeps saying like, no. I
haven't finished. Right? So what it does is
that
it'll set up so we have these things
called wakers,
and wakers are basically a way to tell
the executor that, like, hey. The thing that
I've been waiting for is now complete. I'm
ready to be scheduled, so let me run
effectively.
And so what'll happen is that your task
will run and then it'll,
like, yield or say, you know, it's pending.
Then
when it's ready to run again, it will
call this, like, wake object or it'll get
this wake object and call wake,
and that'll reschedule you back onto the executor.
So
in this case, with Tokyo, for instance, because
we didn't reschedule
it, nothing happens, basically. It just
it just, like,
we've called it once, and then it never
tells Tokyo again that, like, I'm I'm ready
to be pulled again. And so nothing happens
until that happen, like, until
you you wake your task, basically, or your
future.
Okay. Got it. Thanks. That makes sense. It
does. Cool. Cool. So so yeah. So that
that basically
that's
and
where was that?
Yeah. Cool. So oh, okay. Cool. So now
we can also have, this
we can just return ready as well.
And so
this will do what you would expect it
to. Like, it'll print out this. I've been
pulled and then print hello. So
cool. Yeah. So so now we've got this
feature that
basically does exactly what we wanted to. And
it's actually not that complicated as as we've
seen here. Like, we've been able to create
one,
you know, without
without too much ceremony. Obviously,
real shooters are way more complicated.
And so yeah. And so that's pretty much
like
the that's on on on having or creating
your own features
and then wake us.
Cool. I don't know if you have any
more questions.
Yeah. I I guess so. Like,
you know, people wouldn't really be expected to
implement a few shares on their own. In
fact, it'd probably be discouraged. Right? Just use
Yeah.
Just use what is already provided.
Yeah. Pretty much.
Okay.
Yeah. And and that they I mean, there
might be there probably are cases where, like,
it makes sense to create your own. But,
like, most most likely you would just use
what's in the ecosystem already or provided by,
like, the library itself.
It's
it's nice to see how it works all
the way down. Like, you know, now, hopefully,
people have the knowledge that they can add
the Tokyo Executor to their applications.
They, you know, they know that they can
then go and create features or use functions
that return features and how to block and
away on these things or let them run
asynchronously. And
just
seeing that it's just a tree implementation with
a pull function on it was was quite
nice. Like just
I mean, I should have thought about it
and then, of course, it's Rust. Of course,
it's gonna be a trick, but, you know
Yes. Yeah. The the Seeing
it and it's just really cool. I like
that a lot.
So It really is cool. I mean, like,
I think they've done quite a
quite a good job of of the of
the implementation details and, like, I mean, like,
it works. It's also pretty exciting to to
do it yourself even if it's something, like,
very small like this.
Only because it's been seemed like
crazy.
It's, like, nice to see or to know
that it's not the craziest amount of magic.
Like, you can do something very simple and,
like, put it up your own thing.
Yeah. Which is yeah.
Which is pretty cool.
Cool. So,
like, to kind of, like, end off
well, it's not end off because it's gonna
still take some take some time, but thought
it would be cool to, like,
run through.
So Tokyo has its own
well, it has, like, a tutorial on, like,
making your own executor.
And so I thought it would be cool
to just kind of, like, walk through that
just because it, again, like, gives a bit
more context into, like, how things are put
together.
Oh, definitely. Like, kinda, like, super interesting.
Cool. So
we'll make a new file here.
Cool.
So I'm gonna be jumping back and forth
just, like, copying code from from that tutorial.
So that's on, like it's on the it's
on the website. Like, if you go to
Tokyo.rs
and you go to, like, the I think
they've got
something. Yeah. Learn. They have a, like, a
tab called learning. You go to async in-depth.
They have a tutorial there.
So yeah. I mean, it's it's really I
encourage everyone if you're, like, interested in the
topic to read through it because it's really
it's really interesting. And, I mean, it's obviously
a very simple executor, but it's
not, like,
nearly as complicated as you would have thought
it would be, surprisingly.
It's it's simple
simple examples that teach us. Right? I mean,
in a complex example, I'm gonna walk away
more confused than than I came along. But,
yeah, simple works well for me. I like
simple.
Yeah. No. Same. Yeah. Same. Yeah. Cool.
Just give me a sec. Yeah. Take your
time.
Cool.
Alright. Okay. Cool.
Sweet.
Cool. So yeah. So,
yeah, off the
off the bat, we'll have this, like so
we're gonna we're gonna start off I'll I'll
kind of go through it, like,
you start off with this, like, executor,
and then you have and then we'll kind
of, like, build all the constructs going down,
which will be fun. Let me just see
if I have everything I need here.
Cool. So, yeah, just off the cuff, we'll
have this
tequila.
And
that's
so so yeah.
First thing that we'll have is, a a
task queue, and then
let's say
trying to think of a of a descriptive
name for this.
Send to
execute a queue. Alright.
So we're just gonna use a cross beam.
So cross beam is like
actually,
I don't have a good description of cross
beam myself. I'm just
I was actually just going let's see if
it gives us no. It won't give us
anything.
Wait.
Yeah. That gets me every time we've rust
analyze. If you don't use the code, it
doesn't get all complete or anything.
Yeah. That happens throughout the time. Right. So
we've got tools
for concurrent programming. That's what cross beam is.
Okay. Perfect. I know exactly what that is
now.
Better than any description I could give you,
so we're just gonna go with that.
Cool. So, yeah, we've got this cross beam
channel, and so this will just be a
so there's gonna be some details here that
I I might just, skip over, honestly,
but it's cool.
So
awesome. Let me put this, like, send the
So it's starting to look a bit more
like go now.
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, in channels.
So
yeah. So we have this.
Cool. So yeah. So for this executor,
basically, we have
so this task will will kind of, like,
create
a thing next. But,
basically, the idea here is that you have
an executor. And in our case,
we have this task queue. So this is
the the, like, queue of task that the
executor has to run. So when task gets
scheduled on, obviously, backlog the queue, and then,
you know, it'll just go through here to
figure out, like, what to run next. And
then this send to execute a queue, I'm
just calling it this just because it's easy
to understand, like, exactly what it does. But,
basically,
we're gonna this is the sending
side of this of the channel.
And so what we want is for a
task to be able to, like, send
itself
onto
the task queue.
And so we're gonna just, like, pass this
down into the task itself
in essence. And so that's kind of, like,
why it's there.
So
just adding, like, some methods here. So we're
gonna add this in.
Cool. So
just creating a new
new executor.
Also
so send
to executed key.
So
this just created your
so this just creates the
unbounded channel, so there's
no, like, capacity
or yeah. No, like, set capacity for it,
basically.
And then we're just gonna
turn that. So
Then
we have this function called run,
which
basically was the it's gonna be our entry
point. So we're gonna go, like, execute a
dot run, and it should basically run all
the parts that are there.
So
this looks
like
task queue.
Even then,
they're gonna pull the task itself. So here,
all we're gonna do is just, like, run
through each task once it's received
in the queue and then just pull that
task
until
until it resolves, basically.
And then
last function.
Stuff
here. So this
actually, you need to figure out exactly why.
Oh, so for
I mean, this is just a tutorial, so
I'm just kinda, like, copying it from there.
I'm just typing it up just so everyone
can can play along or follow along.
But, yeah, it's got, like, the so this
is the kinda, like, the one that trade
bounce sort of well, yeah, the trade bounce.
It's gonna be sent, I think, because of
cross beam channel needs to be sent. And
then
this static, I'm not entirely sure. I'm not
gonna lie. That's something I haven't I haven't
wrapped my head around entirely,
but I have a very strong feeling
that
it's got to do with
actually, it probably doesn't have to do with
penny. It might. It might. But, yeah, that
that's something I'm yet to
yet to figure out entirely. And so Yeah.
I just throw lifelines around whenever things don't
compare and offer the best. I'm just like,
yeah. Sure. Static. Go for it. Does it
work? Yeah. Done.
Literally.
Oh, no. This is the wrong thing to
So
it seems here, like,
what an executor is is is send and
receive channel with a couple of functions to
add stuff to the queue and then to
run the queue. Yeah. Like yeah. When you
break it down like this, you're kinda like,
this this makes sense. Like
That's really cool. It's really cool. Obviously, this
is very watered down, but nonetheless, I mean,
that's it's basically like the premise
of what's going on. So so yeah. So
now we have
our executor, yeah, with the queue.
And then you can see here in the
spawn function,
we basically
pass this, like, send to exit. So, okay,
a task firstly, like, wraps a feature and
adds a little bit of functionality to it
on, like, state management, I guess. And then
we're passing this, like, send to execute a
queue.
What's the number for?
Like, sender, I guess.
And
this the task will be able to use
to basically, like, reschedule
itself onto the queue.
So
cool. So that's that.
We can then go on to, like, implementing
our task. So, yeah, I'm also just gonna
copy this
in. So
cool.
Alright.
Alright. Let me actually just make a
So
Will that use statement work with a mod
statement?
Sorry?
You said use create task task, but without
a mod.
Does that work? Yeah.
It does work. As far, I mean, as
far as I know.
I think
it should work. Well, we'll see. We'll see.
Yeah. Yeah.
If it doesn't, then we can just use
mod.
Cool. So
so, yeah, we have this task. The task
is just gonna be a feature, and then
that, like, send to
execute a queue,
basically,
which
which will be the same as
one form. So we've got this
and then that takes in a task. And
then this feature is it's just complicated.
But
basically
so it's basically
Yeah. A pen and a box.
Damn it. Yeah. I don't know.
And the and the mutex. And the mutex.
Yeah. And the mutex. Yeah. It's The only
thing that's missing is ARC, and then it's
got pretty much every
all the words I hate.
So the mutex is to make it sync
because cross beam channel requires
things to be send and sync.
And I think sync is a market trait.
Sync and sender market trait. So that means
that if
all of it's
like
I forgot what the what the right word
is. Like, variables or or whatever that belong
to to task,
if they are all synced, then task will
be synced. If they're all synced, then task
will be sent. And, like, if, you know,
one of them isn't synced, then the whole
thing's not synced, basically. So it's like a
it's a auto trade, basically.
So this mutex is needed to make it
synced.
And then
on on pinning,
pinning is
something I'm still also just learning.
But
in effect, it's it's because Rust features
or or yeah. Rust Rust features are
they need to be self referential. They need
to have the capability of being self referential
so they can refer to their own, like,
variables that they constitute of. And so if
they if they've moved,
then you can imagine, like, let's say you
have something sitting at, like, location x
and the feature then is moved in memory
and it's pointing to itself,
then that
that part where it's pointing to itself gets
invalidated because it's moved in memory. So you
wanna pin them so that they don't get
moved, basically. So can you remove the move
semantics then? Like, keeps it in the same
that have been Yeah. Yeah. So it it
basically it basically disallows certain
operations from happening on
something that's
pinned, basically.
So
yeah. So it it doesn't actually, like,
stop anything from technically happening. It just disallows
certain functions from from a like, I mean,
using certain functions on those on those objects,
basically. There you go. There that's the most
important thing I think I've learned today. So
now we know that we've got this dynamic
trait thing of dynamic size thing in memory.
So we wrap it in a box. We
use a pen to keep it at the
same point of memory. So that you refer
to itself with a mutex
so that we can control what speaks to
it in order. Yeah. Got it. Pretty much.
That's
pretty much it. Cool. So, yeah. So then
we have this task and then we're just
gonna
implement
some of some of its stuff. So
okay. First, actually, what could be more interesting
is to have this
did I
I import this? I don't know. Okay. No.
I haven't.
K.
I don't know if I've got this.
I can't get added. So let's see.
Sweet. So we have this
thing called Arc Wake, which
basically allows us to implement the that that
wake and
wake by ref
functionality.
So that's also a trait. No
surprise.
And that's and that's needed for for us
being able to, like, wake a task and
just basically reschedule it back onto the executor.
So in our case, we're just gonna implement
this wake by red
one.
May I ask an adjacent question just now?
Gotcha.
What's the difference between the standard future feature
and
the creates features?
I don't know. Cool.
So I I would at least again, from
what I know. So when they stabilized,
like, the future traits and everything, that's obviously
what's in standard in the standard
library.
And a lot of the, like, design and,
I guess, API development and all that happened
externally,
similar to, let's say, like, how Tokyo and
ASIC standard are kind of, like,
core functionalities of how you'd use async Rust,
but they're not provided by the standard library.
And so that was initially all in this,
like, futures crate.
But then some of it got stabilized and
put into standard. But then there's still a
bunch of functionality that's only available
in, like, the actual features crate. And so
you'd you'd basically use that to add, like,
the additional functionality
in essence. Yeah. Okay. Pretty
much. So we have this
schedule here. And
so, basically, what's gonna happen or the premise
here is that when
we call this wake bar ref
or wake, we're basically just gonna schedule it
back onto the executor here using this function,
which we'll implement now.
So
so that's scheduled.
Oh,
so
yeah,
cool. So we've got this function
schedule
fix.
Oh, and so a weird thing, like,
also like a gory implementation
sort of like detail.
But
setting up these, like, wake functions
requires kind of, like, some low level unsafe
code. And so
an easy way to kind of, like, avoid
that is to use this arc wake. I
don't I don't understand, like,
how it negates or how it solves that
problem for you in effect.
But, yeah, it's basically kind of like a
shortcut from having to deal with routing that,
like, unsafe
code yourself,
basically.
Oh, so then we're just gonna
also then when when you wanna schedule a
task, we basically call the schedule, which will
get called by, like, these wakers.
And this will this is basically sending it
to what what I call this executor
send to executor. Yeah. I was gonna say,
where's executor coming from? You just threw me
for
Just threw away a bunch of it.
And so,
yeah, we've got the center executed queue, and
then we send ourselves basically all this task
to that queue.
And then
I'm actually just gonna
copy and paste this.
So I'm so then and then we also
have this
poll functionality here, which
yeah. And so
effectively,
when we when we pull this
task also because I've got twenty minutes left.
When
we pull this task, we basically create a
waker and a context, and that context is
used when you pull the future internally.
So we've got we've we have, you know,
a feature attached to the task.
This will never fail purely because no other
thread is actually trying to unlock it, so
we can just unwrap it.
And then we pass that context
into
into the future itself,
which is that which will then get called
by that, like, future when when it wants
to wake itself up, basically,
as well.
And then the last part also, I'm just
gonna also copy and paste this in,
which
is that spawning function
functionality.
So this is actually this is actually quite
simple way. When you wanna spawn a task,
we
basically create a new
yeah. So when you wanna spawn a task,
we basically create a new,
well, a new task
object,
and then we send it to
oh, this is not sender. This oh, yeah.
I thought it is. And
then we send this to the the task
queue, basically. So that's what gets passed in
here.
This send to execute a queue. So every
time we spawn a task, a task will
just basically send itself or or send it
a a task
to the executed to get to run, basically.
So that's
that's basically that. And those are the two
kind of, like, big
components.
And then all we have to all that's
left to do is create our own
what is this?
I have no idea.
I will figure that out this time.
So,
yeah, all that's left to do is, like,
create our own future. I also
for the sake of time, also just copy
and paste that and and just kinda, like,
talk through it,
which would just be, like, a lot faster.
Yeah. Go for it.
Cool.
But I also need to solve this issue
now.
This is you're probably right. Yeah. Let's see.
I think you still need to use, but
you need to mod Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't see what's going on here.
What's
going on? And this whole module.
That is super weird.
Okay. We'll get back to that.
That's probably why. K.
Let's see.
So
oh,
I've got a lot of errors coming.
It's unresolved
import.
That should be fine.
Cool. Just give me a sec.
So what's the error on your used future
statement?
Oh, it just says unresolved imports.
I think it's just not picking up that
it's there. Let me see if I can
just, like, reload my window and see if
that solves any of my issue, which I
doubt, but let's see. Yeah. Yeah. Rust analyzer
does seem to flick after a while, and
I usually restart Versus code. So Yeah. It
does happen every now and again sometimes,
but we'll see.
Think it's still building?
Yeah.
Yeah. It's still building a bit.
Well
k.
So
It's still giving me ill. I know it's
changed.
Cool. So that's fine. Here? Yeah. That's definitely
happier. Let's see if this works now.
Ah, there you go. Ta da. There we
go.
Back in business. Cool.
Sweet. So
alright. And then
k. We can actually kinda get rid of
all of this.
And
then there's just this last piece where we
have a
Let me just get that solved.
Curation.
Cool. So we have this, like,
future delay,
which is kind it's almost like a sleep
in effect.
And so, basically, what happens is
I should probably should have written this one
out. But,
basically,
what's happening is we basically wanna delay for
a certain amount of time. So we have
this thing called the instant. Instant just gives
us, like, an instant in time right now.
Basically, these are comparisons.
And so we wanna say, you know, we
want our delay to be,
what's the like,
from now plus two seconds, and then only
after two seconds will be finished. So in
this case, what we have here is if
the current time or, like, this current instant
is larger than when we specified it to
be. So, like, maybe, like, instant
plus two seconds from wherever we are, then
return call ready. Otherwise,
we then go ahead and set it up
to basically tell us when to reschedule itself.
Here, what happens is, k, we've gotten this
the waker from the context,
and then we're kind of using, a a
semi hackish way, I guess. I don't I
don't know.
But we basically spawn a new thread, and
then we we sleep that thread for that
period of time that's left. So,
you know, if we wanted two seconds ahead
and we're actually one second ahead, then we
wanna sleep for one second. And then once
that's done, then we call this waker dot
wake. And this is important because if you
don't call waker.wake at some point, then your
executor will basically hang. Or this task will
never get finished
or run to completion, purely because it never
gets working. It never gets, like, rescheduled
onto the executor to run.
And then we have this, like, poll pending
in this case. So
this will return poll pending, and then once
this wake up at wake runs,
it'll get executed
all again rescheduled and then executed. So that's
basically you can ignore those.
So
this waker. Wake is basically what gets called
here,
the self dot schedule, which then again
sends it to the execute queue.
And then I think we're pretty much good
to go. So we can go
let's actually do this.
And
then
Cool. So we get a new executor,
we
gotta create a new feature.
So
this delay,
then we want back an instance.
Think you can do this plus.
K.
I think that should be fine. Cool.
And then
then we wanna spawn that task, basically. So
you wanna spawn
the future,
and then we want to run, basically.
And I think
that should do the trick. So this should
and when you do a cargo run, create
your new executor,
create a future that we just created with
the delay which just looks for the timestamp
offset.
You then spawn the future and then hopefully
wait and what we should see is yeah.
I was gonna say, yeah. Let's get some
principles. Let's
say, pending, cool, and then we'll say,
we are done.
Don't forget the emoji. I think we need,
like, a confetti emoji or something. Let
me go grab one quickly.
Okay. Cool. And then this year, we can
actually this will be cool because then we
can say, like, we can see that the
task
was yeah. Making the task back up. I
don't know what the
k. Let me go get this great
emoji from someone.
Emojipedia.
That's a good one.
There's a shortcut on the Mac for emojis,
and I can't remember. Oh, really? Yeah. I
can't remember what it is because I've got
mine set up as the function key, but
I think that's option.
But I think you can do the
command shift and something. I'm gonna look it
up. Completely irrelevant though, but I'm gonna look
it up.
K. Cool. Yeah. So we should expect
it to pin then to complete that, say,
waiting the task,
then we are ready.
Hopefully,
let's see how it goes.
If you had a drum roll.
Where in the what happened to my which
I don't know where I am in my
computer.
K. I think we're at the right place
now. It's control command and space bar for
future reference. There we go. Cool. Cool.
Oh, oh,
now just to wait. I know.
The fastest compiler ever.
It's it's I do like that they do
make speed improvements. I do it's it's easy
to make fun of the Rust compiler, and
I do it often. But I also appreciate
that it's a complex piece of software, and
people are content. They're trying to make it
better. So %. I mean, there's that also.
It gives you a lot of guarantees. Like,
it's a it's a basically a kind of
like trade off between what it offers you
versus like how fast Yeah. Definitely. It compiles.
So
yeah. It's it's alright.
Let's see what happens.
K.
Alright. Pending my task ready. Cool. But then
It's still hot. I don't know. It's still
hot. I have no idea why. Oh, no.
That makes no. That makes sense because
this is this is a blocking
this thing is still running. Alright. Alright. Okay.
And this blocks and this blocks. So it
worked, basically. So I guess if we added
that I mean, we don't need to do
it. But if if we checked in the
task queue is empty, we could just exit.
Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Something like that. Yeah. We could
we could do that. But in theory, like,
let's say if you're running a a web
server, you wouldn't wanna do that for instance
because
you can get traffic at any point in
time. Yeah. May not be a very good
web server.
Cool. So, yeah, that's basically that's basically that.
Yeah. That's that's everything from my side.
I'll pop with I hope that was enjoyable.
No. That was that was great. Like, I
I think,
you know, going over all the primitives and
then seeing how they're actually implemented under the
hood is, you know, like, it's not wildly
complicated even though it can feel like it.
And I think you did a very great
job of just breaking it down and showing
us the primitives that we have to work
with.
And it really for me personally just cemented
a lot of those things that I had
big question marks on. And I'm like, oh,
those now make a lot more sense to
me. To me that was a really valuable
demo. I thought that was great. And I
know Awesome.
How the executors work. It used to be
something I would try away from.
Yeah. That's like the best function that has
a pull on it and stuff like that.
So very, useful. Thank you. Awesome.
Thanks.
Alright. Well, we are approaching time.
We got a lovely comment there from Russell
saying that was an awesome demo. Thank you
very much, Samuel and David. I mean, I'll
take some of the credit for sure, but
it was definitely a
% all Samuel there. So thank you for
taking time out of your day, for joining
us,
and for doing live coding, which I know
is no easy feat. So Not at all.
Especially my first time, so it wasn't too
long. Oh, damn it. Oh, well, you did
great. Thank you very much. Thank you. Alright.
Well, I'll let you get back to your
day. Any final words before we say goodbye?
Cool. I'm
good.
That's awesome. Alright. Awesome. I'll speak to you
again soon. Have a wonderful day. Thank you
all for watching. Bye.
Yeah.